[Music]
we have we have a clip here from the
movie anything we need you to set up
this clip as a gentleman uh I feel weird
that it's a date about or - movie about
dates and we don't currently have dates
yeah yeah yes no that's handy but I
don't know I don't know I'm married
I don't feel the connection here just
sexually so we're uh sorry sorry we have
to show a clip for Mike and Eve need
wedding dates but we need like a
teenager to watch the clip I uh I'm
actually seeing some potential candidate
[Applause]
find him
[Music]
anybody
[Applause]
there we go
[Applause]
hey how are you have a seat wow the
light feel awkward Andy you're my date
get over here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is actually my mom found my mom in
the audience when I decided scoop her up
and be like I feel like let's show the
clip these girls gotta go we should be
practicing our speech for tonight not
babysitting the twins from the shining
let's just chill out focus on TV and try
not to be [ __ ]
the rest of the weekend okay can we do
that I can't do that David
because I saw our little sister well
let's just say she was making this face
what she saw saw goes she was David with
the masseuse what yes I'm gonna walk in
on mom giving daddy a push pop I made it
up Dave it's a sexual term that I just
made up what's a push pop I don't know
what's a push pop I don't know what
don't push by being in the bowels of the
Internet and I've never seen a push pop
god that'll be wonderful
- OH - I'll send you some links
[Applause]
yeah this is your not good these are
your new jobs you're sticking around
you